I have had the opportunity to watch NFL
games in space maybe a year ago or so
they were able to to get a projector up
there that can now you can actually see
if it's it's certainly not a 70-inch TV
or anything like that I was actually on
board during the Superbowl so the Super
Bowl actually took place in the middle
of the night for us but I just got up at
the very end of it and saw the the wild
interception at the end so that's the
only live part because we do get live TV
beamed up and those are some of the
improvements that have happened slowly
over the years now we do have calm gaps
that occur that whatever you're watching
and you might miss the critical moment
or something of that nature hopefully
one day in the future we'll have just a
table in front of us and the game will
be like a hologram when you're living on
the International Space Station for a
long duration like that you lose touch
with what life is like I remember when I
landed there were things that I didn't
realize i missed while i was on orbit
until I got back around him there's no
breeze there's no rain there's no snow
one of the first weekends I was back I
was standing out in my backyard and it
was raining and I was just standing
there enjoying the rain falling on it
because you haven't felt it in a long
time and
you know walking barefoot in the grass
right that you don't have any of those
kind of connections with home when
you're living in space so ways that we
can find find ways to keep people
connected I think are very important so
whether that's with video or with news
or with with sporting events right
sporting events are such a big part of
our lives here on earth why shouldn't
they be a big part of our lives when
we're up in space and going to space was
absolutely wonderful one of the best
experiences I've ever had but one of the
great things about going to space is
coming back home it's coming back to
earth this is a wonderful planet it's a
great country to live in and and going
away from it kind of helps you remember
that